[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrancy internacional y de France
24 esta semana no es la semana santa lo
que ha inspirado nuestro programa de
esta edición pero sí que tiene que ver
con usos y costumbres verán esta será la
época recordada por la época en la que
la humanidad se puso a perrear y vamos a
hablar de eso del reggaetón como
fenómeno cultural y social que está
impregnando absolutamente todo en el
mundo
nos acompañan para hablar en esta
edición ansyroll periodista
independiente que ha escrito sobre
feminismo y reggaetón bienvenida
es bailarina coreógrafo coreógrafa e
investigadora en danza bienvenida
Melissa Serrato periodista cultural
bienvenida Buenos días Carlos y Ingrid
Gamboa periodista especializada en
culturas urbanas bienvenida Muchas
gracias
el perreo tendencia mundial hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
clasismo conflicto intergeneracional
letras misóginas el odio al reggaetón va
más allá del gusto musical hay una parte
de la sociedad que no lo aguanta y otra
que lo ama casi que no existe La
indiferencia en el asunto que hoy nos
ocupa en los últimos años la
incorporación de mujeres a la música
urbana ha producido cambio de
perspectiva el perrear contra el
patriarcado se ha vuelto tendencia el
éxito de géneros latinos ha colocado el
perreo en la agenda feminista actual hoy
vamos a analizar las razones sociales y
culturales que lo explican también si
existe un clasismo cultural a la hora de
acercarse al tema en cualquier caso aquí
lo vamos a hacer sin complejos
atendiendo a que si hay un fenómeno de
la cultura latina que ahora mismo Está
impregnando al mundo ese está siendo
impulsado por figuras como Bad Bunny
Rosalía Karol G repasemos algunas
portadas revista Time ha dedicado una
portada al fenómeno Bad Bunny el mundo
de bad Bunny no voy a hacer otra cosa
para que a ti te guste
Daddy Yankee Otra de esas figuras que ha
transportado al reggaeton a otro nivel
de social en la portada de Rolling Stone
figura de del reggaeton que llega a la
cima dice la publicación el país en este
artículo que se refería al tema de hoy
clasismo conflicto intergeneracional
letras misóginas el odio al reggaeton va
más allá del gusto musical bueno quizás
deberíamos de empezar hoy hablando de si
hay muchos prejuicios a la hora de
analizar el perreo como fenómeno social
y cultural han Bueno creo que es muy
interesante porque al oxígeno reggaeton
era un ingeniero muy patriarcado muy
machista con letras súper violentas
comparadas mujeres a veces y ahora vemos
hoy en día que hay una nueva escena
súper interesante de mujeres
empoderadas
de su deseo sexual y que están
reproduciéndole
es más se puede bailar reggaeton
escucharlo incluso defenderlo siendo
feminista
primero se diría que qué es lo que
estamos entendiendo cuando hablamos de
feminismo este hubo muchas luchas
plurales que hacen muchos feminismo pero
si estamos hablando de una lucha contra
opresiones múltiples del sexismo del
racismo del racismo ahí sí pienso como
el perreo como
lugar donde el cuerpo explora su
libertad su placer su goce me parece una
fuente una herramienta potente de lucha
claramente feminista y además el perreo
puede ser mucho más puede ser fuente de
erotismo de auto erotismo puede ser
combativo también como en las en las
manifestaciones en Puerto Rico en frente
de la catedral y además conlleva
memorias este de migración de gestos
pélvicos donde este lugar que
históricamente hoy en día está
violentado constantemente cosificado se
rea retoma Y en este sentido desde el
baile mismo sin escuchar las letras con
el ritmo ahí me parece un un poderoso
una poderosa herramienta de feminismo y
vosotras que sois periodistas culturales
desde el periodismo hemos mirado muchas
veces con clasismo al género del
reggaetón Y eso nos ha impedido analizar
todo el fenómeno cultural y social que
estaba en ebullición Melissa en los
primeros tiempos sí y cuando uno ve las
entrevistas de los reguetoneros dicen
que realmente tuvieron que pelear y
tocar muchas puertas para lograr entrar
a tener una entrevista en un medio de
comunicación y ser visibilizados pero
pues de ahí a lo que vivimos hoy pues es
decir es que está absolutamente
impregnada nuestra sociedad de de
reggaeton entonces claro el fenómeno de
la resistencia que hubo a lo que hoy es
es totalmente un crecimiento exponencial
hemos quitado estigmas entonces
Siempre hubo la atracción de la buena
sociedad de la alta sociedad para para
esa cultura clandestina la cultura
underground que ese mestizaje estaban
necesario para que la cultura pueda
revivir crecer Evo lugar en muchos
sentidos Entonces se alimentó la cultura
de la alta sociedad con la cultura
clandestina eso fue siempre y yo creo
que el reggaetón vivió también ese está
viviendo también ese fenómeno es esa
historia este
en dos décadas el reggaetón pasó de ser
un género urbano más que de todo
localizado en el Caribe en Panamá un
género mainstream he criticado por
violento por misógino hemos hablado y
por Su riqueza musical discutible Cómo
se puede
definir esta evolución que ha tenido el
reggaetón en dos décadas creo que la
evolución es muy interesante cuando
vemos artistas como Bad Bunny él está
cambiando toda todas las reglas del
valoraríamos las dos décadas devolución
yo creo que hubo lo que se podría llamar
un violento blanqueamiento de un género
en sus orígenes afrolatino en unas en
los conurbano en conurbanos para
autorizados del Caribe Panamá República
Dominicana y cuando está cooptado por la
industria musical muchas veces basada en
Latinoamérica en Estados Unidos ahí sí
hay un proceso ahí de sexualización
obvia cuando antes también era cultura
de de sobrevivencia de hablar de los
barrios de los problemas de las de las
drogas del crimen de todos los problemas
que estaban en los barrios de la
violencia continua
hipersexualización llegó cuando empezó a
ser más en mainstream cuando salió de
las fronteras de en este momento se
sexualiza mucho porque también es lo que
la gente pide y entonces en este momento
estamos viviendo la sociedad que se está
hipersexualizando y y se está liberando
todo esa partida
íntima de todo el mundo es el ser humano
el movimiento de cadera es la matriz del
de la humanidad sí o no entonces La
pregunta es la coreografía del reggaetón
y su hipersexualización condiciona las
nuevas generaciones o es liberalizadora
para mí es liberadora porque porque
estamos levantando la tapa de un pudor
que estaba asfixiando el cuerpo los
contornos de del cuerpo de sobre todo el
cuerpo de la mujer
de su manera de respirar sus emociones
todo eso teníamos una tapa Y esa etapa
que hay una contradicción porque por un
lado Es verdad que se es liberalizador
para la mujer puede ser incluso
emancipador Pero por otro por otro lado
insistimos en esa hipersexualización no
hay una ambigüedad ahí es central creo
es una danza ambigua que a la vez puede
desde adentro sentirse erótica auriónica
pero no solamente al sentirla pero a
verla puede producir
es grotesca es obscena y justamente
Calle 13 decía es un baile tan obscenio
que cuando uno lo mira le da vergüenza
ajena y justamente nos propone la
transgresión que hasta donde nuestra
sociedad acepta Cuáles son los límites
entre lo bueno lo malo lo moral lo
inmoral lo limpio lo sucio todo eso esos
binarismo de nuestra sociedad sin duda
podemos recordarnos de la religión y de
todas las las límites que nos puso la
religión yo creo que ahí estamos casi en
el jardín del Edén con Adán y Eva y y el
el y la mujer que tal vez representa la
la tentación y tal vez algo más
diabólico el latinoamérica el
catolicismo ha impuesto por la
colonización tan con manera tan
que ver con que las mujeres están
revolucionando la música urbana y eso
está teniendo efecto en el tema que hoy
tratamos decir también hay una
incorporación de grandes figuras al
mundo del reggaeton de grandes nombres
de mujeres Sí yo creo que las mujeres
están reapropiando y se necesita que
esas mujeres que esas figuras femeninas
se
reapropían ese ese el reggaetón Y esa
música porque las mujeres van a tener
otro punto de vista del reggaetón y se
van a liberar tras esas esas cantantes
me parece al fin al cabo no se trata de
nuevos códigos como han existido tantas
veces en el pasado que a su vez
escandalizaban otros generaciones decir
esto este recorrido Melisa que vemos con
el reggaetón No lo hemos visto antes con
el rock con El hip hop por otros géneros
Sí por supuesto es decir también siempre
ha habido mucho miedo a lo nuevo en la
sociedad entonces llegan los Beatles y
este sonido estruendoso que a la que al
que la gente no estaba habituado Pues
por supuesto genera resistencias y los
temas de los que habla también por
supuesto Siempre la música ha hablado de
sexo pero digamos que de una manera
mucho más sutil hablaba y también el
roca también habla ha sido misógino ha
tenido letras totalmente
recuerdo una canción de Guns n' Roses
por ejemplo que dice solía amarte pero
tuve que matarte Porque te iba a
extrañar mucho Entonces estás ahora Tres
metros bajo tierra en mi jardín Claro ya
no consideraríamos acá
de culto pero pero sí O sea decir
resistencia siempre ha habido pero yo
creo que también lo que es interesante
es que el reggaetón de una forma u otra
va está muy en sintonía con el tipo de
relaciones que hoy estamos teniendo
entonces no es extraño No sé que Maluma
cante for babies que una de sus
canciones más escandalosas
gústele a uno no pero
cuántas personas tienen hoy dos o tres
citas en tinder para ver con cuál
funciona y con cuál no y y también Creo
que es un género sumamente
claro popular y
significa con una realidad que se está
viviendo
un fenómeno espejo entonces en esa
realidad que a lo mejor otros géneros no
no identifican tanto han
así podemos hacer un paradero con el
baile brasileño porque tenemos la misma
cosa viene de los barrios de las favelas
y la gente está muy pobre
condicionada en pequeños barrios y hay
códigos muy violentos vemos armas en los
videoclips y recuerdo del expresidente
Javier bolsonaro a que le odio mucho
este género y creo que pasa la misma
cosa cuando hay un fenómeno de Espejo
social como estábamos comentando Emma
que Pues quizá por eso se haya vuelto
tan popular no tanto en las relaciones
incluso pero igual creo que desde el
inicio mismo hoy en día mujeres
reapropiándose desde el inicio había
mujeres que no hay que estaba Ivy Queen
cantando Yo quiero bailar Pero eso no
quiere decir que para la cama voy desde
el inicio había mujeres bailando
empoderándose y ahora Tal vez sí que
ahora se ha vuelto mainstream y está
está apropiado culturalmente por y está
codificado está haciendo de
contextualizado está haciendo Sí
claro reapropiado desde otros lugares y
por mismo por también este comunidades
no heterosexuales que se reapropian de
la hipersexualización justamente para
reivindicar orgullo de sexualidades
de la palabra hace una breve pausa y
enseguida volvemos hablando del perreo
en esta edición de en Primera Plana
[Música]
France 24 su ventana al mundo
libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando del perreo como tendencia
mundial del reggaeton lo hacemos con
ankiroll periodista independiente que ha
escrito sobre feminismo y reggaetón nos
acompaña Emma Georgia investigadora en
danza y las periodistas culturales
Melisa Serrato e Ingrid sellen antes de
irnos a la pausa estábamos hablando de
la importancia de esas mujeres que
han digamos puesto aún más de manifiesto
en la escena internacional el reggaetón
el perreo Melissa es que hay algún hay
una pequeña precisión que a mí me
gustaría hacer Y es que claro decimos
que a partir o gracias al reggaeton las
mujeres empiezan a hablar de su deseo y
de sexualidad y yo quisiera traer a
colación dos ejemplos que me parece que
son muy anteriores al reggaetón y que
nos dicen nos hacen evidente también que
las mujeres de una forma u otra cuando
llegaba a tener voz para hacerlo también
hablaba de su deseo y de su sexualidad
pienso Por ejemplo en una canción de
Rocío Dúrcal que dice Invítame a un café
y hazme el amor
clarísimo y hay otra que también me
encanta en este sentido Y es de Rocío
Dúrcal y dice Y le canta al marido y le
dice hace tiempos que no siento nada al
hacerlo contigo entonces es decir no por
supuesto las mujeres en el reggaetón han
tenido un papel absolutamente necesario
y lo aplaudo totalmente de que hablen de
su deseo y hayan haya salido la
intimidad y se cante la intimidad y sea
para todos es un Bravo pero pero decir
que solamente las mujeres reggaetoneras
llegaron a hablar de deseo sexual y
liberaron
no no me parece no me parece justo con
otras mujeres que han antecedido y que
lo han hecho y que en su momento era más
difícil hacerlo el ritmo al que se mueve
la música urbana actual es así
vertiginoso y cambiante tan rápido que a
veces es difícil de esto sabe muy bien
Ingrid que estudia mucho las culturas
urbanas Qué componente hay de brecha
intergeneracional para hacer falsos
diagnósticos porque a lo mejor también
aparte del tema del feminismo también
hay una brecha intergeneracional por la
que a veces no llegamos a lo que
escuchan la gente de 18 de 20 años
Ingrid sí Siempre hubo ese choque entre
las generaciones los jóvenes siempre son
los primeros a poder entender y sentirse
reconocerse en las nuevas culturas las
culturas clandestinas Y eso nos puede
llevar a falsos diagnósticos vista con
la perspectiva del adulto no por no por
no entenderlo bien Sí sí sí Y además los
adultos después se bueno primero negan
la la parte cultural el aspecto cultural
de eso y hablan más de algo societal y
finalmente viendo que hay una evolución
y es el joven que tiene que probar que
sí es una cultura que sí hay un medio un
medio de exprimirse un medio de tener
mensajes de decir lo que piensa la
juventud por dentro entonces después el
adulto y sobre todo los adultos del
círculo del arte de la cultura de la
moda como fue por el hipo el hipo pan
presenta era en la calle una cultura de
la calle y la la en Nueva York los los
especialistas de moda entonces empezaron
a interesarse para alimentar a su
círculos a su arte y a su cultura y así
llegó y así hoy en día tenemos el
Breaking que está en los Olímpicos de
París
A lo mejor para explicar esta brecha
intergeneracional tenemos que asumir que
culturalmente nos vamos volviendo
conservadores con la edad y lo que
hacemos es seguir haciendo hincapié en
los gustos ya preestablecidos tenemos
miedo a descubrir cosas nuevas
culturalmente
una cuestión de sensibilidades no es
decir
para que cualquier manifestación
artística te llegue pues te tiene que
decir algo te tiene que te tiene que
tocar de alguna manera y hay personas a
las que el reggaetón No sé si sea
solamente una cuestión generacional y
personas de nuestra edad que adoran el
reggaetón a mí personalmente no me gusta
pero porque no me toca no me dice nada y
pero es una cuestión también de
sensibilidad no no sé qué tanto sea de
generaciones qué pensáis para mí me
gusta mucho el reggaetón y me ha
encantado mucho
es bueno yo ya entiendo Cuando dices que
las letras pueden ser como machistas y
lo sabemos todo pero me gusta como
cuando leí un libro
puedo gustarme mucho pero no no estoy
Adictiva a la narrativa y creo que
cuando escuchó Romeo Santos no es
reggaetón lo sé pero no tengo que estar
de acuerdo con todo no pero una pregunta
ahora cuando os veo a hablar y ya tenéis
una libertad a la hora de decir me gusta
no me gusta el reggaetón se ha quitado
parte del estigma en este tema porque
hasta hace tan solo unos años decir me
gusta el reggaetón en ciertos círculos
sociales estaba mal visto Incluso si te
gustaba era casi un placer prohibido que
no que no decías no cómo lo ven sí
depende donde
en España en Latinoamérica no depende de
donde te criaste en que ámbito en que y
creo que tampoco no tiene
depende de dónde venís para uno es un
estigma para otro es una pasión
inmediata pero sí siempre está eso de
los pasos prohibidos está esa ambigüedad
continua que de la cual hablamos revela
algo íntimo del ser humano como en el
baile contemporáneo la primera vez que
nishinski subió en el teatro vestido con
todo ese ese costumbre bien apretado y
ahí nació el baile contemporáneo porque
él reveló el cuerpo del bailarín con una
gestual también que nunca se había visto
igual por sus Vega que era una una
bailarina en París y bailaba con su
faldita de bananos y todo y la gente de
la alta sociedad iba a verla en el
cabaret y estaba lleno estaba repleto
del teatro más temas hablemos de lo
latino porque lo latino en todo este
debate se habla de música latina o de
ritmos latinos que proyecta esta música
de lo que es entre comillas lo latino
hablamos de algo tan globalizado que ya
la particularidad latina sea diluido
cómo lo ven Pues para mí son ritmos
el latino la cultura latino nació de ese
mestizaje de ritmos africanos europeos
amerindios y ese mestizaje yo creo que
sigue viéndose y tratando de vivir en el
reggaetón también no Melisa
sí habría que también definir Qué es lo
latino pero pero si podríamos partir
derecho de que es lo latino es también
lo que se habla o se canta en español y
hay algo que me parece muy particular
También acá y es que el reggaetón
utiliza algo también muy frecuente hoy
en día y es el spanglish Entonces ya no
es solamente ya no es solamente el la
influencia y el mestizaje de atrás sino
que claro es decir como es mainstream y
como ya llegó a todos lados y estamos
invadidos por reggaetón entonces claro
también incluso personas que no hablan
español
les gusta el reggaetón y tal vez Para
complacer también a ese público
internacional se usan palabras en inglés
y es spanglish para hacerlo más cercano
Incluso si lo latino Es una construcción
una ética una etiqueta de la industria
musical que aplasta el multiculturalismo
de lo que es la latinidad el latino los
latinos también son las construcciones
nacionales en América Latina que usaron
el mensaje pero siguiendo implementando
leyes racistas Entonces como el
mestizaje o la
hibridez real y también los latinos es
adentro de la diáspora en Estados Unidos
mismo acá en Europa cuando se vive se
conoce entrevisté a un bailarín que me
decía que él bailaba todos los fines de
semana reggaetón para sentir la
latinidad a través de sus venas Y eso es
muy fuerte es como también la identidad
cuando en la experiencia de la migración
que ahí sí es no es más una etiqueta una
construcción pero que se vive
profundamente en una era en la que el
odio se propaga sin control en internet
los artistas urbanos han aprendido a
convivir con las críticas más sangrantes
porque quizás ningún otro movimiento
musical ha recibido un nivel de rechazo
tan pronunciado como del este del que
hablamos hoy Esto es esto Al fin y al
cabo tiene la parte positiva de convivir
con la crítica y asumirla es decir es
decir si la viralidad de YouTube
proyección hubiera sido imposible pero
al mismo tiempo han tenido que asumir
una carga de críticas y de rechazo muy
profundo no de una generación de lo que
estamos hablando de la generación que no
entendía que no estaba sensible a eso
pero vemos Que en tiktok es las redes
sociales la más vista por la la juventud
y todo Pues las que te las primeras
personas que tuvieron lo más followers
en en su cuenta fueron las niñas que
bailaban y que movían la cadera y que
tenían justamente esa sensibilidad Y esa
esa hipersexualidad también de de eso
Entonces yo creo que sí es así es éxito
en 2017 marcó algo creo porque
fue súper súper raro en todo el mundo y
desde este tiempo creo que antes habían
como la gasolina Dale y todo pero creo
que eso explotó todo en el baile el
cuerpo sin duda se convierte en la
expresión material del individuo a
través de él revelamos emociones y
sentimientos como decía antes Ingrid
significantes culturales y prácticas de
vinculación con el entorno le pregunta
la coreógrafa de ahí que se produzca el
choque del perreo como forma de
emancipación
A ver
es una expresión absolutamente impúdica
y que rompe con la sensibilidad
convencional lo que vemos con el perreo
hoy las mujeres digamos que afrontan esa
nueva controversia Y si el poder y la
represión social sabotean mi
empoderamiento es decir por qué no puedo
gozar de un momento sexy sin tener que
sentir culpa sin ser menos sin tener que
sentirme menos respetada o menos humana
Sí porque también está el sentir y está
el contexto con quién estoy bailando
Dónde y cuándo Entonces eso está
obviamente puede
pero hay algo de que bailar el perreo es
como quitarse la culpa de algo quitarse
cómo lo venan creo que sí porque cuando
se van a las discotecas vemos jóvenes
latinas o no bailando y perreando y las
chicas quieren bailar solas con amigas
con un hombre Pero como dice Ivy Queen
no es porque
con un hombre que quiere ir a su cama la
liberación del cuerpo me parece que es
la liberación del cuerpo y que ahí con
el reggaetón se se muestra esa intimidad
y y no es la primera vez porque por
ejemplo la cultura Duque que es del
Caribe francés Es bien pegado son se
baila de a dos también y todo y ahora es
algo aceptado en la cultura francesa las
fiestas normal y y ahora sí se acepta
pero al primero la gente que bailaba sub
no era no era bien vista Sí perdón es un
poco lo que decía Andrés como la esa
reapropiación ese retomar ese lugar del
cuerpo que fue tan violentado tan
cosificado retornarlo con Orgullo y y
usar de su poder y negociar el deseo que
genera Entonces sí es ahí es un lugar
fuerte de empoderamiento claramente
Melisa
recuerdo justamente
una una frase muy famosa
una dramaturgo Irlandés que decía el
baile es la expresión perpendicular de
un deseo horizontal y me parece
absolutamente diciente para este tema
porque hay por ejemplo recuerdo la
última canción que hizo Shakira con
Karol G
están juntos están en la sobre la arena
emulando de alguna manera los
movimientos del acto sexual es decir
creo que Hemos llegado a llevar esta
música el perreo y el reggaetón a su
máxima expresión de tiempo para más ha
sido un placer hablar con ustedes de
perreo en esta edición de en Primera
Plana y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana Muchas gracias gracias